de la gauche iséroise présente une liste
unique en france baptisée un engagement
commun elle est emmenée par un élu non
encarté guillaume gontard et rassemble
une diversité de mouvement en on s'est
regroupé on s'est retrouvé pour essayer
de battre constituer une liste d'un
large rassemblement avec des formations
politiques
les communistes europe écologie une
partie des socialistes avec les tirs et
la ligne et benoît hamon et puis aussi
des citoyens non encartés
j'en suis un exemple guillaume gontard
mène cette liste avec le soutien de la
sénatrice communiste sortante annie
david
et en bon architecte de profession il
espère que la construction de cette
alliance inédite donnera des idées pour
le futur
moi j'ai j'entends parler à chaque fois
mais qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi
cesser ces gens qui ont les mêmes
valeurs arrive pas à se rassembler
arrive pas à travailler ensemble
ben là on prouve que c'est possible et
donc on espère qu effectivement ça fera
des petits il ya les élections
municipales en 2020 et que ça sera
justement encore une nouvelle occasion
de montrer qu'on peut travailler
ensemble didier rambaud et lui aussi
issu des rangs de la gauche mais il est
désormais la tête de liste pour la
république en marche dans le département
comme tous les candidats ils visitent un
maximum de communes et défends partout
la nécessité d'un groupe macro nist
important au sénat
on peut pas avoir d'un côté une
assemblée nationale où il ya la majorité
présentielle
et puis un sénat où il y aurait que
l'opposition qui s'exprime je pense
qu'il ya une espèce de déséquilibre qui
serait qui porterait préjudice au bon
fonctionnement de ce quinquennat engagés
de la première heure derrière emmanuel
macron didier rambaud espère transformer
l'essai même si la dynamique victorieuse
du printemps s'est atténué la haye le
vent n'est pas dans le dos et on l'a
plutôt un peu de face il ya eu peut-être
en termes de communication cet été 2 3
annonce qui aurait mérité d'être d'être
recadrées ou plus précises c'est vrai
que voilà il faut être clair pour
l'avenir il faut au moins donné à cap
fixé 1 4
donner de la visibilité face à ces
départs en cascade les socialiste de
l'isère ont désigné une valeur sûre en
tête de liste le sénateur sortant andré
vallini mais son espace politique s'est
restreint après la perte de nombreuses
municipalités en 2014 et du département
2015 est désormais les divisions dans
son camp le contexte a changé
incontestablement il ya des élus
hamonistes qui ont décidé d'aller à la
gauche de la gauche et de trahir encore
un peu plus le parti socialiste il y à
des socialistes qui effectivement sont
passés du côté de emmanuel macron et qui
ont abandonné leur idéal socialiste
moi je reste fidèle à mon idéal à mes
convictions je suis de gauche je suis
socialiste fidèle au parti et
expérimentés
l'ancien secrétaire d'état en charge de
la réforme territoriale puis des
relations avec le parlement ne se voit
pas dans une opposition systématique au
gouvernement le sénat sera là pour dire
aux députés et aux gouvernements
attention sur les collectivités locales
ne fait pas n'importe quoi
cesser de les attaquer de les dénigrer
de les étrangler financièrement on sera
dans une position non pas d'opposition
systématique mais de vigilance la gauche
part divisée mais la droite n'est pas en
reste pas moins de cinq listes
dissidentes ont déposé leur candidature
face à celle conduite par michel savin
investi par les républicains en campagne
dans le nord du département le sénateur
sortant mis sur le terre
art et je dois souligner aussi que lors
des récessions précédentes vous aviez
aussi et elle se finit ce soir
aujourd'hui notre huitième semaine de
campagne
on a commencé au mois de juillet parce
que encore une fois pour nous et nous
paraît prioritaire d'aller rencontrer le
maximum de grands électeurs une
proximité avec les élus locaux que le
sénateur revendique et qu'il compte
encore développer en cas de nouveau
mandat
moi pendant six ans j'ai travaillé bien
sûr avec mes colistiers mais aussi avec
des élus de toutes sensibilités sur des
sujets qui était débattu au sénat parce
que je pars du principe que j'ai pas la
connaissance parfaite de tous les sujets
j'ai besoin d'avoir le ressenti des élus
qui sont concernés par les textes qui
sont débattues et de pouvoir travailler
avec eux sur corrigé améliorer les
textes qui sont aujourd'hui à l'ordre du
jour avec des listes en présence pour
cinq élus au sénat
l'élection risque d'être serrée et
malgré les divisions
chaque camp espèrent faire le plein pour
siéger à la haute assemblée